a third night a third vote and a firm
decision to put the brakes on brexit the
ice right 412 the nose for the left 202
so the eyes have it the eyes have it I'm
no MPs overwhelmingly backing a motion
to try and extend Britain's plan
departure from the EU Brussels now has
to sign off on the delay which would
last until June if the UK approves a
deal in the coming days failure to agree
a deal could lead to a much longer
postponement and potentially to no
brexit at all for Prime Minister to
resume whose planned to leave the EU has
been rejected twice fear of losing
control of Breck's that might just be
enough to get staunch brexit backers in
her own party to finally support her
plan in a third vote in Parliament next
week the EU insists that May's plan
which is the product of two and a half
years of painstaking talks is the only
one on offer if the United Kingdom still
wants to leave the European Union and it
wants to leave in an orderly manner
which is what the Prime Minister tells
us then this treaty such as it is which
organizes the orderly separation this
treaty is the only one possible and
available a disbeliever on the streets
of London people on both sides of the
debate vented their frustrations
well I think the most sensible solution
would be that we leave on the 29th of
March with no deal but there's easy to
say sorry we've made an absurd mistake
absurd mistake it's no question about
that in my mind I'm astounded absolutely
stand by what's going on think it's a
complete shambles utter chaos it's so
much fun this is what politics should be
no one knows what's going on nothing's
being arranged by anyone it's all
falling apart
don't you find this entertaining
scrambling for a way out of the
country's worst political crisis in
decades two and a half years after
voting to leave the EU it will now be up
to Brussels to decide if they want to
help Britain make a clean break with the
block but how long might that clean
break take joining us now is DWS
baguette moss in London and aunt Regan
in Brussels good morning to both of you
if we could start with London and Bergen
what do lawmakers Bergen want to gain
with this extension
well lawmakers know that they're really
at the end of the write and in two weeks
time the UK would crash out of the
European Union if no solution is find so
there's really a necessity for
Parliament to just do something they
can't really agree on any way forward
and they just had to just agree on this
one thing which is to ask the European
Union for for one extension because
threesome a is trying one more time to
get a deal through Parliament that's
going to go that's going to be next week
she's got one more chance but she can't
bring all the breakfast at a brexit
legislation through Parliament in two
weeks time even if her deal passes so no
other choice really okay Banten Brussels
now they'ii use Donald Tusk is saying
he's open quote - a long extension to
give Britain time to rethink what it
wants is this an indication that
Brussels believes it's possible to keep
Britain inside the European Union but as
it stands now this would be of course
wishful thinking the Brits want to leave
the EU
the common sense here toast is trying
just to open another window of
opportunity maybe to think about the
second referendum or something that
might change the cause but realistically
there will be a question for extension
at the next leaders summit here in
Brussels and the leaders will grant this
this extension that is for sure because
they don't want take the blame for a
crash out brexit or whatever comes then
so Mrs May will get the extension until
30th of June most probably to try then
either to implement a deal or to find
another imagine jority for a deal with
the EU and of course the European
elections are coming up then and this is
very difficult to extend the extension
after the 30th of June because the
Parliament will constitute itself in the
first week of July ok a baguette there's
some new possibilities now for Theresa
May what are the chances that the Prime
Minister will pull off an unlikely
victory and get her brexit plan passed
in the end really and unlike victory
because her deal is really hated it
hated of course by those who want to
remain in the European Union because it
falls behind the deal that the UK has
now with older it's opt outs but it's
also hated by those who really advocated
for brexit because in their mind
Teresa Mays deal just locked the UK too
much into the European Union also in the
future and this is why they cannot unite
behind it here or they could not so far
we've had in the last days that some of
those who were more on the right wing of
the Conservative Party who opposed the
deal
they might just change their mind
because they know if it doesn't get
through Parliament one last time next
week then anything could happen
it could be a longer extension like
Bennett has mentioned it could be a
second referendum the brexit vote might
be overturned so they might not want to
run that risk that will be decided next
week in yet another crunch vote here in
London about the EU first part has so
many
issues right now migration and security
are just two of many how much is the
focus on brexit preventing brussels from
moving forward with its own agenda but
of course brexit is overshadowing most
of the summits and discussed mercy in
brussels and there's a kind of a brexit
fatigue you can sense it here in
Brussels there some people that say just
push them over the brink and let's get
over with it but I would think the
majority of the
Eurocrats and bureaucrats here in brazil
brazo say we have to play along with
Teresa's maze tactic because we don't
want the negative effect of a crash out
brexit we have to manage the brexit and
just give the Prime Minister what she
wants we we have to run around in
circles as we did in the last two years
and just sit and wait what the British
will do okay so time of is of the
essence both in Brussels and in London
many thanks this morning to Bantry it
and to bigoted Maas there in the British
capital